from stray coffee cups in westeros to
Bradley Cooper's fake baby things don't
always go as planned when filming a TV
show or movie there have been numerous
mistakes in the past decade that slipped
through the cracks and made it onto the
big and small screen here are 18 of the
biggest blunders of the 2010s in 2019
HBO aired the final season of Game of
Thrones and while fans weren't exactly
happy with how everything turned out
with the rushed plot there was also a
major gaffe that managed to throw
viewers completely out of the fantasy in
this scene a coffee cup from craft
services no it's technically not a
Starbucks cup was accidentally left in
the final cut it's clearly visible on
the table next to Daenerys and as far as
we know there were no baristas at
Winterfell the cup was later edited out
of the shot after the coffee cup debacle
no one would have expected yet another
mistake in the final season of Game of
Thrones in one of the most important and
highly anticipated scenes of the series
the leaders of Westeros were choosing
who would take the throne
I suppose this is the most important
moment of our lives
unfortunately someone on the cast or
crew left some water bottles in a few of
the shots turning the serious moment
into a bit of a joke there's a
heartwarming moment in American sniper
that quickly turns laughable in this
scene Bradley Cooper has returned from
war and he's picking up his child but
since director Clint Eastwood thought
using a real baby would be too
unpredictable they decided to use a doll
instead and it's painfully obvious
especially when Cooper is seen moving
the baby's arm with his finger the
events in season 5 of Breaking Bad are
set in 2009 and 2010 but one of the
characters can apparently see into the
future in this scene Todd's uncle
references the raid and death of Osama
bin Laden whack and bin Laden wasn't
just complicated which didn't actually
happen until a year later in 2011 in the
Dark Knight Rises the son seemingly sets
super-early stockmarket high scene takes
place soon after the opening bell
and it's clearly light outside but soon
after there's a car chase and when they
all emerge from the tunnel it's
pitch-black Dark Knight Rises indeed but
that wasn't the only mistake in the film
typos happen all the time but the copy
editor at the Gotham Times probably lost
their job over this one in the main
headline on the front page heist is
spelled wrong in this scene Rachel
McAdams character is writing down notes
from our conversation with one of the
abuse victims at a diner the camera cuts
to the notebook several times and while
she seems to fill up the page a few
shots later it's nearly blank
maybe it's disappearing ink during the
final battle scene in The Avengers
there's a lot going on so it's not that
surprising that there would be a few
continuity errors here in this scene the
front of a car is clearly dented and
beaten up but after Thor lands on the
ground the car has miraculously turned
to perfect condition a blessing from the
gods there's another continuity error in
the final battle
here we see Captain America is shot in
the stomach and is suit is torn and
damaged a few minutes later however it's
back to normal
guest Captain America is also a pretty
good seamstress Elsa belting out let it
go is one of the more memorable scenes
in frozen but no matter how many times
you've watched it you may not have
noticed this one pretty bizarre era in
this scene after she lets down her hair
she swings around and her braid appears
to magically pass right through her arm
[Music]
Suicide Squad wasn't exactly flawless
but there was one scene in the film that
makes absolutely no sense and this scene
the characters were all putting on their
costumes but Harley Quinn's
transformation is a bit more drastic
than the others somehow she manages to
get a haircut and dye her hair seconds
after she puts on her outfit
seriously the hell's wrong two people
while technically not in the show this
promotional image for Downton Abbey made
headlines for something fans spotted in
the background can you find it yes like
Game of Thrones there's a plastic water
bottle in the shot sitting right there
on the mantel may have been too
teary-eyed at the sight of all the
Avengers assembling to notice this one
in this scene we clearly see tannaz
destroy Captain America's shield it's
cracked in half but soon after when the
camera pans out at the portals opening
the shield is back to its original state
if only we could snap our fingers and do
the same for Iron Man Henry Cavill is
known as Superman but he appears to also
have superpowers in his role as agent
August Walker and Mission Impossible
fall out in this scene cavils beard
quickly grows while he's punching as if
that wasn't bad enough a pocket also
appears on his dress shirt in the world
of The Walking Dead physics apparently
don't apply in season 5 Daryl and Carol
are trapped in a van that's teetering on
the edge of an overpass eventually the
van Falls and flips forward but somehow
it lands on its wheels
seconds later before the coffee cup and
water bottle there was another error in
Game of Thrones that had people
scratching their heads in season 6 we
learned Melisandre turns into an old
woman when she takes off her necklace
but in season 4 there's a scene with her
and a bathtub saans necklace and yet
she's still young and beautiful while
demagogue goons and strange young girls
with telekinesis aren't very realistic
there's one mistake the production team
on stranger things made with the props
throughout season 1 the kids are using
realistic TRC 214 walkie-talkies to
communicate with each other the only
problem is that these didn't actually
exist until about two years later in
1985 while there's certainly a lot of
time hopping in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe one jump in spider-man
homecoming seemed to mess everything up
the movies supposed to be said eight
years after the Avengers which was set
in 2012
hence homecoming takes place in 2020 but
that doesn't line up with the rest of
the films like Avengers infinity war
which was set in 2018 so the entire
timeline would get shifted making the
dates the heroes jump back to an endgame
in correct director Joe Russo eventually
admitted that this eight years later
title card was incorrect during a press
interview were there any other big
mistakes you noticed in the past decade
let us know in the comments